Này, mình chỉ thích 3, 4 hội thay là nảm ầu lại ông Anutin, Travea Rhoa Cun, làm thủ tướng,
với 2 chăm chỉ 3 phía ủ hồ, vẫn mức tổ thường cần thiết.
Theo ẵn tìm ái Pé Đy Tín, khi còn này gió ông chủ thành nhà lãnh đạo đầu tiên tại đất gửi
tại thay là nha sau hương 2 mi năm.
Tuy nhiên, chính cộng mới sẽ phải đủ mặt với nhiều thích tất.
Bà hồn về tăng trưởng kinh tệ trọng lại và tất động từ tình hình cải trình đâm.
A Pé cũng cho hay giá như lượng tăng và giá nợn gồm đang gây ác lực lên đến tình tệ thay là nha trong trường như thế này.
Tụi tướng thay là ná Nytin, Travea Rhoa Cun đã trưởng tập của họ của chúng tang quả lý và giám sách chung về tình hình chung đông.
Để gấp dút giải quyết tấn tề khăn giếm như liệu,
được khi nhận tạng dưu trọng xanh trên phẩm đi càng hước.
Há là nả gấp dú trụ đồng đứa giá các giải pháp, để giảm thiệu có đồng từ các khu xúc năng lợt.
Để kể đỏ tham tạo phục phủ xuất lịch của Thay Lan sau đại dịch, cũng đáng đối mặt với trường gại lớn khi xuống đột lâu tháng ở chúng đông làm sáng đoạn các tuyên bài toàn cầu và anh hưởng đến tâm lý dù khách.
Zulic chim tới hà miệng chăm chú đếp hệ Thay Lan, nế nước này cũng năng nghen trong đưa ra chế lợt.
Hoa ra khăn tham biết giới về các vüc chiế tế tục là vấn đề cận xử lý.
Các trường dành ở tiêm chức mắt của chính phủ sẽ là ở địa kinh tế và gửi phó với cậu tổ bên ngoài.